the streamer awards are done and as you
may have guessed there were some pretty
funny moments some call outs but listen
you know what mango did do he supported
smash bros more than a certain company
called nintendo did and when everything
was said and done and all the awards
were handed out streamer of the year
went to ludwig
[Applause]
probably took you a little off guard
especially if you're a long time juicer
i am actually pretty shocked that xqc
didn't win that last one but for xqc it
wasn't really a surprise whenever we did
the voting uh for content i clicked on i
clicked on my own square and i
immediately like i mean like turned off
the page or whatever i don't acted like
it like it didn't exist or something
because i didn't want to skew the votes
to make it like um like like a popular
vote type of thing but he says it's not
really an excuse
it's more like earning them in places
that i can't manipulate them i think
they makes these it makes these awards
more like worthwhile